I once said that Peter Pan was sore like
every little boys fantasy I mean think
about you got pirate you got flying you
got Indians you got faraway lands you
got mermaids if somehow they worked in
cowboys and spacemen this movie will be
set and for what the story is Disney
does it pretty well
they've course put some changes here and
there but they still get the
characteristics of these people down
really great pan himself is very cocky
and sure of himself and I have to admit
he has a little bit of product of the
times something about that voice in the
way he loves you can definitely tell it
was done in the 50s of course that's why
I like him I tell him to The Lost Boys
but he never uses anchoring catchphrases
or anything
Wendy once again is portrayed by Kathryn
Beaumont again sort of taking your bland
typical innocent and turning into
something really entertaining she's a
wonderful nurse although father says
girls talk too much his girls talk to
him hmm
well get on with it girl my name is
Wendy Wendy Moira Angela darling is
enough oh I can surprise they didn't use
her in more films after this you got
John the geek and Michael the cute
innocent and they all go off on an
adventure to never Neverland where they
never have to grow up The Lost Boys are
typical delinquents and the Pirates are
typical pirates but what I really love
about this movie is Captain Hook again
this is sort of the Captain Hook most
people think of when they think of Peter
Pan threatening but he's also really
really funny Smee as well as sort of the
definitive Smee
he wants be mean-spirited but he's just
too bumbling and nice plus when you put
the two of them together with the
crocodile dude this is some of the best
slapstick you'll ever see the timing the
pacing the expressions it kills me every
single time i watch these scenes
the romance between Wendy and Peter is
just perfect it's not overdone they
never actually share a kiss on screen
it's very much done like how real little
kids fall in love girl often Watson more
and the boy doesn't know what the hell
to think of it Tinkerbell is a nice
bitchy character that also gets a
Redemption at the end and the Indians
they're definitely an archetype of what
we thought Native Americans were at that
point I don't know it's sort of like the
black crows from Dumbo I never really
found them that insulting I thought they
were cool that song what makes the red
man red I love that song it still sticks
in my head what made the red man
Peter Pan seems to get the childlike
adventure down pretty well for little
kids it's pretty gender-neutral the
girls can get into the romance and the
mermaids and the flying and such well
the boys can get into the sword fighting
the pirates and all that good stuff the
energy is great the imagination is great
it's just a good old-fashioned fun kids
movie it's definitely one of Disney's
most biggest trademarks for a reason